Okay, let's go next to our caller from the
six three zero area code.
Who's calling today from six three zero.
Hi David.
My name is Clark.
I'm from an Algonquin Illinois.
Hey Clark.
Great, great to be on the show.
Um, I, I just got to say, God bless you for
what you do and I'm going to come right out
the door with, um, connecting with what I
just said there.
Um, what do you think about the statement
claim proposal from that of someone who is
vehemently in support of Andrew Yang?
Would love a Yang VP?
I'm sorry.
Um, a war Yang President Warren or Bernie
people.
Well, but yeah, even VP, I, you know, Bernie
won Yang.
I have them, I'll take any of them, you know,
don't get us stuck with it.
Like there, there's a field called, we're
not going to name any in particular, but anyways,
what do you think about the suggestion for
people?
Like, for example, Jessie Lee Peterson all
the way to Donald Trump, so that of people
that are left bleeding and not necessarily
believing in the ideology that's claimed to
be the foundation of the Republican Party,
which is family values.
And I would say the sentiment and, and values
of Christ Jesus.
Which themes?
Absolutely hip hop, like the most hypocritical
thing in the world to anyone that actually
spend any time learning about the teachings
of values Christ.
What would you say to the suggestion of why
not utilize the Bible and other, I mean, really
just interpretation of it, but I mean, even
just scripture at face value, like when I
was listening to the, I recently started listening
to you and when I heard the Jessie Lee Peterson
interview, I was like, this guy has to be
either completely just the master of trolls
or he truly is like just absolutely brainwashed.
And I really tend to think it's the latter
for the majority of the people.
But what, what do you think about that suggestion?
Because I, I mean that's, that's generally
what I go to when I get at it with, um, people
that really try to use the Bible as a rhetoric
or as, as, uh,
hold on.
I got it.
I'm sorry I got interrupted because I don't
know what you're talking about.
You're saying what do I think about using
the Bible to justify political positions?
Yes,
I'm against it.
I believe in separation of church and state
and I think no matter whether you can, hold
on a sec, I believe that no matter whether
you can make an argument for or against the
policy on the basis of the Bible, I don't
think that should have at any part in our
sort of national discourse.
Now at the individual level, I have no problem
within, for example, and Evangelical Christian
community, I have no problem if within that
community people want to start saying, hey,
you know what?
If we really want to vote the values of our
congregation, we should be voting for this
left wing candidate over this right wing candidate.
That's great.
From the point of view of the national discourse.
I don't think that the Bible should be a factor
in how we make law or policy.
And for me personally, it's not relevant,
but for Progressive Christians absolutely
go and advocate for the Bible actually suggesting
progressive ideas rather than conservatives.
I think that that's great.
Well for, for someone who has, I would just
say as well informed as yourself that encounters
people that use this.
Um, I mean regardless of if you believe in
it, it's very frequently utilize as a counter
argument.
It is, well the Bible is very often the Bible
has stimulated huge amounts of republicans
support on the basis, particularly of the
issue of abortion for a while on the issue
of gay marriage, et Cetera.
So I think fighting fire with fire is great.
It's just not for me as a, as an individual.
And I don't think it should be part of the
national debate on what laws we should or
shouldn't have.
Okay.
And then can I just ask one more question?
That's a completely different realm.
You know, I've got 42 people holding, so that
I think call back for the next question.
I really appreciate your call.
I do want to get to somebody else before we
run out of time.
No problem.
Thank you.